With just a few steps, you can add
beautiful buttonholes to your doubled
button bands.
Be sure to watch this entire video.
We'll go through the steps and then go
back to see how we can improve on our
button holes.
Now this takes practice, so please
practice before starting on your sweater.
In addition, we're assuming that you're
familiar with picking up and knitting a
doubled band . We'll be knitting an 8 row
band with a turning row and three stitch
buttonholes.
Start by pulling out the needles that you
need for your band and open the latches to
make things easier.
With the private or the wrong side facing
rehang your garment edge on the machine.
At
garment tension, knit 4 rows.
These are the sets of buttonhole
needles that I needed.
Mark the needle bed, so it will be easier
to identify the correct needles as you
form the buttonholes.
Next, put in some provisional stitches.
That will be the start
of the button holes.
Using Ravel cord, use a contrasting color,
knit by hand, each set of three stitches.
You can control those ends with clips.
Still knitting at garment tension, knit
another four rows to finish the first half
of the band.
Knit a turning row.
I just chose to loosen my carriage
tension to 10 for this row.
Starting knitting the
second half of the band.
Don't forget to adjust your tension.
You'll want to knit the second half of the
band at garment tension minus one and knit
4 rows.
This is the first half
of this side of the band.
Now the fun starts.
We're going to pick up the bars at
the top of our provisional stitches.
Pull out the first set
of three marked needles.
To correctly form the buttonhole.
You'll be picking up four bars, doubling
up on the three buttonhole needles, plus
one more.
Do this for all the buttonholes.
Now look closely.
Those provisional stitches are still in
place and they're still holding 3 live
stitches that will form the
other half of the buttonhole.
Pick up the top bars for
each of the buttonholes,
placing the strands on the
marked needles plus one more.
Next we'll bind off to
secure those stitches.
Using a separate strand of yarn and the
method of your choice, bind off these
stitches.
Secure the last bind off
stitch on the adjacent needle.
Your buttonhole needles are now empty.
Don't panic.
The holes look really big and
sloppy, but we're not finished yet.
Continue binding off for
each one of the buttonholes.
Secure those bind off strands by
wrapping them around the edge needles.
I like to hang clips to tighten
up slightly and secure those ends.
Remember those three live stitches
that are being held below.
Now's the time to pick them
up and finish the buttonhole.
Identify each stitch and hang it
on the corresponding empty needle.
Do this for each one of the
sets of buttonholes needles.
Still knitting at your garment
tension minus one knit 4 rows.
The knitting of your band is complete.
Before we close up the band, you can
remove the ravel cord provisional stitches
and finish off and work
in those bind off strands.
Now please keep watching this video.
I'll talk about my boo boo that I made
here and some other options for this
entire technique in a minute.
Buttonholes are finished.
The band knitting is finished.
Just need to secure the
band to the garment edge.
Now there are a lot of ways to do this.
I chose to pick up the garment
edge and then just simply bind off.
Each side of the band is secured at the
buttonhole edges and the finish is nice
and neat.
Now right off the machine,
the band seems distorted.
These are pretty big button holes
and they're fairly close together.
Once blocked, this band will be beautiful.
Well, let's go back and
look at some options.
I'm going to refer to some companion
videos that will help with this technique.
The videos can be found in the
Knit it Now Buttonhole Classroom.
When you pick up the garment edge,
consider picking up a single loop for less
bulk.
Watch the video Seaming Stitches to Rows.
Be sure to practice picking up and
knitting plain bands before adding
buttonholes .Check the
videos in the classroom.
If you're having trouble picturing which
stitches to pick up, or if you're asking:
" why do you pick up four stitches in
the first part of this technique", please
watch the video "Upside Down
Stitches."
I used a stitch-through-stitch bind off
to close one side of the button hole.
And you can see, the chains that
are formed with that bind off.
If you're a perfectionist, consider
joining the stitches with Kitchener stitch
or a backstitch bind off that
might not be as noticeable.
Check the bind off
videos in the classroom.
Using a separate strand of yarn to bind
off the buttonholes proved to be a little
problematic.
I was kind of lazy and I just wrapped the
loose strands around the end needles, but
I really didn't take any time
to secure those loose ends.
I found that the strands popped out.
Maybe I should have left a longer tail.
But a better solution would be to use a
bridging technique and use the main yarn.
In other words, when it came to bind off
the stitches, put all the needles to hold.
Knit the first set of needles.
And then free pass back.
Use the main yarn to bind off
those buttonhole stitches.
Knit the second set of needles.
Free pass back, use the main yarn to bind
off the second button hole and continue
this across the row.
So instead of using loose strands, you
can use the actual yarn of the garment.
Although this is tedious, it would
really eliminate those loose ends.
The last thoughts on this
technique is more about the bands.
As I mentioned before, you need to be
familiar with picking up and knitting
bands.
There are many techniques for this.
Please watch the video band perfection for
some different methods that can be used
with this buttonhole technique.
A reversible band could also
use this button hole method.
Add your provisional Ravel cord to
one side and work the button hole.
As you knit the second side of the band.
Please take time to master this technique
and try some of these suggestions
yourself.
By perfecting your button holes, you will
take your knitting from looking homemade
looking handcrafted.